PROFESSOR: Welcome back.
So in this session,
we're going to look
at sinusoidal inputs for
ordinary differential
equations of order one.
So here in question one, you're
asked to use complex techniques
to solve x dot plus k*x
equals cosine of omega*t.
Here k and omega are constants.
This is of ODE of first order.
And the sinusoidal
input is referring
to the right-hand
side of the ODE
where basically
the we are forcing
a system with a
function, and it's
sinusoidal of angular frequency
omega, which means basically
a period of 2pi over omega.
So you're asked to
use complex techniques
to solve this in question a.
In question b, we're asked to
use what we had in question a
to solve this modified
function, where again, we
have a sinusoidal input
on the right-hand side
with an additional amplitude
F, which is now constant.
In the third part, we're asked
to use superposition principle
to solve this combined
equation, where now we're
introducing a value for
example for F, which is 3.
And you can see also that
the right-hand side is also
a sinusoidal input, because
it's a linear combination
of sinusoidal functions.
All these equations are linear
with constant coefficients,
and hence superposition
principle would hold.
So why don't you stop the
video, take a few minutes,
and work through the problems.
And we'll be back.
Welcome back.
So what is it that
we're asked to do here?
We're asked to solve this
using a trick that you learned
in class to basically
convert a real-valued ODE
into a complex form.
So the first thing to do is
to realize that the cosine
of omega*t is simply the real
part of the imaginary complex
exponential i*omega*t.
So when we realize
that, and we see
that the ODE is
real-valued linear,
we can convert
this real-value ODE
into this complex-valued ODE.
And we're going to label
this equation star.
From this point, we can
go back to the techniques
that we learned in class,
namely the integrating factor,
to realize that we can
rewrite the right-hand side
in this form, introducing
a new function u,
so that we need
to seek a function
u that will then recover
this function, this equation.
And from previous
recitations and problem,
we saw that clearly the u that
we will need to pick is just
exponential of k*t.
So now from this, basically
we're back to i*omega plus k,
the whole thing t, on
the right-hand side,
and here z*u prime that we
just need to integrate on both
sides.
So this is simply k*t*z
on the left-hand side.
And on the right-hand side,
we're integrating-- again,
it's still an exponential,
even though it's complex.
And we need to
introduce, of course,
constant of integration.
So the solution for the
equation star is then,
I'm going to write it up
here, so that we keep that
for the rest of the problem,
minus t minus k*t when I divide
by this.
And here, the minus k*t of
this exponential is going to be
canceled out by the
integrating factor.
So we need to keep that here.
So here I gave the
general solution
with the solution
that would come
from the homogeneous
equation, which we could refer
to also as a transient
here, because basically
after a long time t, this
exponential, if k is positive,
would decay.
And the part of
the solution that
comes from the sinusoidal
input, or the forcing, which
would be particular solution.
So to go back to the
original question,
we were asked to solve
this real-valued equation.
So from what we
noticed above, we
saw that the
right-hand side is just
a real part of the right-hand
side of the complex value
equation star.
And similarly then,
we can do the same
for the actual
solutions themselves.
x is also just the real
value of this complex number.
So here, for this
general solution,
I'm going to just use c bar for
general complex constant here.
And in this case, we
will take the real value.
So at this point, it doesn't
really matter what t is.
It's just we're going to
keep it as a constant.
And now it's just real valued.
That's for the one part.
And then we need to take the
real part of this expression.
Come back to the line here.
So to take the real
part of this expression,
you learned that
basically you just need
to multiply the denominator
or the numerator
by the complex conjugate.
And that will only give us--
so we have k minus i*omega over
the squares, and then again,
Euler formula that we saw
in a previous recitation.
So x, from this
expression, is just
the real part of all of this.
So it's going to be this term.
Let me factorize
for a moment here,
and then the result
of multiplying the two
complex parts as
well, i to i, minus 1.
And so that answers
part a of the problem.
So if we look at
part b-- I'm just
going to do it
here-- part b we're
asked to do to solve a
very, very similar equation.
And I'm just going to
leave the F out for now.
It's basically
the same equation,
except that the input now is
a sine instead of a cosine.
So we can use the same trick
as we used for question a
by realizing that
now the sine is just
an imaginary part
of the exponential,
the complex exponential.
So we don't need to
redo all the work.
We only need to, if we were
considering this equation,
to just take the imaginary
part of the solution
that we just found here.
And we can just read off
the solution from this line.
Note that in this
expression, I left out
the homogeneous part, which
I should add here from here.
And this was just
a complex part.
So to come back to
what I was saying,
the sine is just
the imaginary part
of the complex exponential.
So we're just going to
write down the solution
by reading off here.
So again, we have
the homogeneous part,
which would be another
real-valued constant,
and then the real part of
this expression, 1 over k
squared plus omega squared.
And its imaginary part then
would give us a k sine omega*t
and a minus omega cos omega*t.
So this would be the
solution for part
b, if we had this equation.
But we actually have an equation
with an additional amplitude F.
And what this
leads to do is just
an additional constant
that would appear then
for this solution.
And we could see that
if we rewound the way
we solved in part a,
and saw that introducing
constant F to the equation is
equivalent to just multiplying
the full equation
with F. And then
in the integrating
factor part, we
would end up with an F
in front of our solution
when we are doing
the integration.
And so basically,
that amplitude could
be absorbed in the
constant of integration
for the homogeneous part.
And the F just remains in
the particular solution here.
So for the last
part of the problem,
we were now asked to use
the superposition principle
to combine solutions of two
previous ODEs that we could
split from this equation, cosine
omega*t plus 3 sine omega*t.
So you saw from
previous recitations
that superposition principle
applies for linear equations.
This is clearly a
linear equation.
And here on the
right-hand side, we
have two sinusoidal functions.
Because it's linear
we can look at this
by splitting it
into two equations.
And I'm just introducing
x_1, x_2 as notation
to distinguish between the two.
And here we can
recognize that we already
did this work that
was in part a,
and we already did
this work in part
b, where F now has a value of 3.
And so what this is telling us,
because it's a linear equation,
we can use
superposition principle,
the solution, if you were to
do the addition of these two
equations, would just be the
sum of the previous solutions
that we found.
So this would be our x_3, if
I had labeled this with a 3.
And so basically, the
solution is simply the sum
of the two previous forms.
And so we would end up
still with our c minus k*t,
which is this basically the
homogeneous part that we
obtained in the two previous
parts, which is common.
And then we just need to
add each particular solution
introduced in part a and part b.
So if I have room I
will write it all out.
So we would have k cos omega*t
plus omega sine omega*t from
the first part of the cosine.
And then we're introducing a
3k sine omega*t minus 3 omega
cosine omega*t.
And that would be then the
solution of the combined two
equations.
And so you don't need to
redo the full work, by using
the superposition principle.
So here the key was just to
recognize that the cosines
and the sines are basically
real parts and imaginary parts
of the complex number, of
the exponential of i*omega*t.
Again, it's just Euler formula.
And using that as
a shortcut to be
able to kill two
birds with one stone
and solve the two equations by
using only one approach, which
is just the integrating factor.
And this ends the
session for today.